[Music]
Hello, how are you? Sal and Jaramillo greet you
with their brief information for today, Monday
, August 30, and it already weakened
into a tropical storm early Monday morning
after being a
category 4 hurricane and making landfall on Sunday off
the coast of  louisiana affirmed and sent
the nevada force
one' rescue team for assistance 28
national teams were called to assist
in the affected area 35
valley firefighters were also dispatched and will
remain there as long as necessary
this morning a pedestrian died from
exaggerated vision here we can  observe the
scene this morning at 4 this crossing
is still closed authorities
advise alternate routes pedestrian
was taken to hospital but did not
survive clark county school district
reported over 100,000 300
positive cases since july almost 600 of these
cases  come from elementary schools
where students are not eligible
for the vaccine in March of this year
physical  o began to study the effectiveness
of their vaccine in children aged 6 months
to 11 years if it were to be approved
then they would do so under
urgent authorization use for
minors aged 5 to 11 between
possibly September and October they
could continue with  an
emergency order for minors
from 6 months
and finally students of the college
is outlined returned to
face-to-face classes this morning if they are
enrolling around 30 to 50 thousand
students each year from
all over the country despite the fact that today
it's the first day of school young people
can still register the deadline is
september 5th also if it's on he's
partying as he celebrates his 50th anniversary
and now we move on to the weather forecast
we'll have a hot sunny day
today with temperatures reaching  107
degrees however temperatures will drop
for tomorrow and
some clouds will appear in the valley we will have a
chance of rain  and the
temperatures will remain
below three digits. have a nice day
sal and jaramillo salute you and this was your brief
informative edition in spanish